i met up with ben shapiro and ben  shapiro in l.a and he said the most ben  shapiro thing to me ever  and his little you know how he talks he  talks about do give me a bench  impression come on  i'm gonna try but he was like you know  you know the conservatives haven't cared  about gay since like 1990 right like  like so quickly like he shook his head  he did one of those things like you know  we don't care anymore right  and i was like it's like well now i know  like i didn't know before but he's like  yeah we nobody cares  if you're looking for more honest and  thoughtful conversations about politics  instead of non-stop yelling check out  our politics playlist and if you want to  watch  full interviews on a variety of topics  watch our full episode playlist  all right over here and to get notified  of all future videos be sure to  subscribe and click the notification  bell